hamma j'en suis très vénéré et je vais
péter un câble autre tête et je suis le
patron de télé câble attention ces
suisses et on a tous connu des moments
de solitude
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
merci merci et sans rigoler dans cette
émission déjà on dit bonjour ils veulent
tous mettent ça veut dire ils veulent
mettre la main sur if les cris les ans
les perruques 2000 où il attendait deux
minutes qu'on s'installe rastkhah c'est
pas possible dans un instant on aura un
accent belge un accent belge puisque on
va faire le tour avec des belges eux qui
sont ici les cours dax hendaye dans un
instant d'ailleurs un petit accent belge
qui à nos amis belges qui sont là c'est
qu'ils doivent être très content parce
que pour une fois ils vont comprendre
les blagues de thierry moreau
[Applaudissements]
bonsoir je suis ravi c'est pas l'accent
belge cher
c'est pas l'accent belge kbc ce canon
une bonne blague belge et ils sont
toujours souriant ouais parce qu'ils ont
la frite nam
[Applaudissements]
gibert nasdaq s'emballer on va manger
une frite ensemble une fois
[Applaudissements]
moi je serrais dire à quel point chic
entendre avant que ça vivre ces taxis
bus l'avez remarqué mais les vénère tous
quand on fait des accents on énervions
sans procès quand tu me l'as remarqué
chez vous dès qu'on fait n'importe
quelle action d'énerver c'est comme tu
sais pas quand on fait si mal et tu
t'étais pas ton maire de man united
baguette tu tombes merde tu verras ce
domaine car je n'ai jamais entendu la
fin
qu'est ce que vous mettez une carte sim
donc ça va être regardé mais quand on
fait pas moi quand je fais l'acteur a
pris non genou et celle çi j'ai deux ou
trois ou quatre aussi comme ça ils sont
tout à fait légaux couach et la sortie
du match en suis très vénéré et je vais
péter un câble optique je suis le patron
de télé câble attention ces suisses
et on a tous connu des moments de
solitude on a tous connu des moments
voilà où on sent vraiment tout le monde
s'écroule compte bien content d'être là
une fois que tu te bouges pas écouté
tout on a fait des actions pourraient
alors là vous allez pas me faire chier
moi oui c'est vrai mais tout le monde
nicolas sarkozy mais fatigué c'est bien
je vais vous dire chers chez moi je vous
le dis en ce que tu te mettes une frite
donc
[Applaudissements]
est ce que tu crois pensé faire un
papier pour laisser ton corps à la
science et aux radios grippe a à télé 7
jours télé
[Musique]